we're on problem 210
a television manufacturer produces 600
units of a certain model each month
so 600
units per month
at a cost to the manufacturer of ninety
dollars per unit
ninety dollars per unit
fair enough
and all of the produced units are sold
each month what is the minimum selling
price per unit that will ensure that the
monthly profit revenue from sales minus
the manufacturer's cost to reduce on the
sales of these units will be at least 42
000 dollars
okay so they want to know the mini
minimum selling price
so let's call that p
so p so how much are they going to make
per unit p minus what whatever their
cost was p
minus 90 that's how much they make per
unit and they do that for 600 units
right and they say that this has to be
let's say be at least 42 000. so this
has to be greater than or equal to
42
000.
okay so we get 600
p
minus what's nine times six it's 54
54 and then we have one two three zeros
fifty four thousand
right nine times six yeah ten times yep
is greater than or equal to 42 000
so then you get 600
p
let's add 54 000 to both sides has to be
greater than or equal to
54 plus 42 is 96
000 and just to simplify things let's
take let's divide both sides by a
hundred so you get six p has to be to
see if you get two zeros here
two zeros here six p has to be greater
than
960
and then p has to be greater than or
equal to don't have to worry about this
because it's a positive number
6 goes into 96 16 times
so it goes into 960 160 times so the
minimum selling price is a hundred and
sixty dollars which is choice d
problem 211
if
4
x
plus three y
is equal to
minus two
and
three x
plus six is equal to zero what is the
value of y well this is a quick one
three x
would be equal to minus six so x is
equal to minus two substitute back here
four times minus two minus eight plus
three y is equal to minus two add eight
to both sides 3y
is equal to minus 2 plus 8
or 3y
is equal to
6
y is equal to
2.
and so that is choice e
problem 212 doing a different color
212.
the data sets 1 2 and 3 above are
ordered from greatest standard deviation
to least standard deviation in which
of the following okay so they want us to
order them essentially greatest
so
set 1 was
set 2
is
74.
it just says 74 a bunch of times
74
74 and then set 3 has
62
then 74
74
74
and then 89. so standard deviation is
how much on average do the numbers vary
from the mean right
in all of these cases the mean is 74.
i'm just eyeballing it right you have
right and this let's see 89 is 15 more
actually here the mean isn't 74.
so first of all this has
every number here is the mean so the
standard deviation is actually zero so
this is going to be the they want to
know from greater standard deviation to
least standard deviation so two is
definitely the least standard deviation
so that leaves us with choices either
b or d
choices b or d
and now we have to figure out which of
these have a lower standard deviation
so here we can just eyeball and say okay
the average is 74. if you average this
and this you get 74 that and that you
get 74.
so what's the difference from 74. here
it's two here it's one here it's zero
here it's
one here it's two right you just want
the magnitude how far away you are from
74 each time and if you were to average
these numbers you get two plus one plus
one plus two that's six divided by five
so you get six over five you know they
square you could even do the variance if
you if you really cared about you could
square these numbers but you just want
to get some measure of on average how
far each of the numbers from the mean so
here's six over five
let's see two plus one three yep six and
there's five numbers so six over five is
the average is the standard deviation
there
what's the mean here this is interesting
so
74 to 89 to have those numbers right
yeah to go from 74 to 89 you have to go
plus let me
let me add these up
let me add these up so
you get
62
actually what's the average of 62 and 89
it's not it's no it's not 70.
it's not 74.
let's see 2 plus
11 is
i'm just going to have to do the whole
let me
well i could just
take the average of i just want to
figure out the mean as fast as possible
so 89
and 62
9 plus 2 is 11
9 plus 6 is 151 you divide that by 2
the mean of these two numbers are
75.5
right
so at least if you're trying to figure
out the mean you could view that's going
to be the same thing as the mean of
so actually let's just do this it's 151.
let's just take the average of
everything 150 i tried to be cute but
this is better to just be brute force
it's so 62 plus 89 is 151 plus 74 times
3
divided by
5.
let's see 74 times 3
74
times 3
4 times 3 is 12 7 times 3 is 21 22
and then 222 plus 151
is
373
and we're going to divide that by 5
so 5 goes into 373.
7 times 5 is 35
23
5 goes into 23 four times 4 times 5 is
20
3
74.6
so the mean here is 74.6 i can i this
this is going to have the largest
standard deviation because
this is 0.6 from the mean this is 0.6
from the mean this is 0.6 from the mean
this number is 12.6 from the mean
right and then this number is what is
14.4 from the mean
so if you're to average these numbers
you're going to get a bigger number than
six-fifths but let's just confirm it
so
12.6 plus 14.4 oh you know you're
definitely going to get a much bigger
number because when you summed all of
these up you've got a 6. when you just
sum up the 12 and the 4.4 14.4 you get
15 you get 27 and then it's going to get
to 29. you divide that by 5. the
standard deviation here is going to be
4. so
3 has the largest standard deviation 2
has the least
so
the correct answer is d i should have
been able to eyeball that i shouldn't
have had to go through all that
computation i took too much time that
wouldn't have been acceptable on the
gmat
problem 213
which of the following is the lowest
positive integer that is divisible by
all of those numbers so 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9.
so the lowest positive integer that is
divisible by all of those
so one way to think about it is
let's just try to minimize our
multiplication right
if we're divisible by
8
then we don't have to worry about
2 and 4 right being divisible by 8 is
enough
right
likewise if we're divisible by 9 we
don't have to worry about being
divisible by 3 because we're definitely
going to be divided by 3.
we need to be divisible by 7.
if we're divisible by 6
well if we're divisible by 8 and 9
then that means we're already divisible
by 2 and 3 and if we're divisible by 2
and 3 then we don't have to worry about
6
right
so we only have to worry about 5 7 8 and
9. so what are those numbers when you
multiply by each other so
if we do 8 times 9 is 72
right 8 times 9 is equal to 72
70 so we got rid of those times
7 is equal to two times seven is
fourteen
seven times seven forty-nine plus one is
fifty
and then that times five
times five
four times five is twenty five times
zero is zero bring down the
5 times 5 is 25 so it's 25 20 and that
is choice
c and i'm out of time see you in the
next video